افاد مراسل الجزيره بان انفجارات عنيفه
ومتتاليه تسمع جنوب مدينه غزه ومعنا من
غلاف غزه الان مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس ابرز ما تمكنت من رصده من تطورات
حيث
انت بالفعل سهام هنالك سماع لدوي انفجارات
عنيفه جدا ومتتاليه من المناطق الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه يبدو انها ناجمه عمليات تفجير
يقوم بها الجيش الاسرائيلي في تلك المواقع
ربما يستهدف فيها مبان او معاقل تابعه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه او ربما تكون هنالك
فتوحات انفاق او انفاق هجوميه يعمل على
تفجيرها كما فعل في غضون الاسابيع
الماضيه وواضح ايضا حيث نسلط الان عدسه
الكاميرا على منطقه جباليا ان المعارك
هنالك ايضا على اشدها وان الانفجارات ايضا
عنيفه ومتتاليه وسحب الدخان تتصاعد من
ثلاثه مواقع على الاقل في منطقه جباليا
التي شهدت معارك ضاريه ما بين القوات
الاسرائيليه والمقاومه الفلسطينيه هذه
المنطقه التي تبدو عصيه حقيقه على الجيش
الاسرائيلي وما يبديه تبديه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من باس وقوه في التصدي للجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ اسابيع متتاليه حتى وان
كانت ال المعارك هنا خفت قبل نحو اسبوعين
لكنها عادت واشتعلت واشتدت في الايام
الماضيه مع محاولات الجيش الاسرائيلي
للقيام بعمليات توغل كثيره
ومتتاليه في تلك المنطقه الان ال قطاع غزه
كله مقطع الاوصال الى ثلاثه مواقع هنالك
ثلاث فرق عسكريه اسرائيليه تعمل في قطاع
غزه وتو وتقطع اوصالها الى ثلاث مناطق
واحده تعمل في المناطق الشماليه وهي تخوض
الان معارك ضاريه تحديدا في منطقه جباليا
الثانيه الثانيه هي التي تقوم بفصل
المنطقه الشماليه عن المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتعمل في المنطقه الوسطى لقطاع غزه تحديدا
فيما يعرف بالشارع رقم 10 والهدف لهذه
الفرقه هو منع انتقال الفلسطينيين من
المناطق الجنوبيه الى المناطق الشماليه وم
وصلت عمليه تقطيع اوصال
الضفه قطاع غزه بين الجهه الشماليه والجهه
الجنوبيه فيما ان الفرقه 99 هي التي تعمل
مع سبعه الويه بشكل قوي في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه حيث يواصل الجيش
الاسرائيلي عمليته العسكريه الواسعه كما
يقول والترجيح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يسعى
الى محاصره قياده حركه حماس السياسيه
والعسكريه هناك وهذا ما كان المح اليه
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي يوم امس حين
قال بان الجيش الاسرائيلي في اطار عملياته
العسكريه اي وصل الى احد الانفاق التي
كانت المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحتجز فيها على
الاقل 20 اسيرا فلسطينيا خلال الشهور
الاخيره وعثر على بعض المقتنيات وبعض
الامور التي كانت مرتبطه بوجود الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في تلك ايه ال الانفاق